I I like Dania because he does fantastic  impressions  if you've seen that um you did someone  on our show last year yeah yeah I think  casparov he can do Kasparov  kramnik uh he's he's he he tried to do  you David but it was I pulled him up I  said Daniel listen uh you've got to work  on the English accent a little bit I  haven't heard that one yeah  for an interview I'm dying to him I  agree especially if he's been refining  it yeah yeah and obviously obviously  Eric is uh is the streaming partner with  your opponent in the chess boxing fight  um on Hamilton yeah yeah the chess bras  uh are they talking about the chess  boxing oh yeah all the time yeah yeah  yeah